Hello everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google.
It is my pleasure today to welcome Jackie.
Okay,
thank you.
Thanks for being here.
What?
We're here to talk about the foreigner.
Yes.
Which is a very exciting and,
and dark and kind of intense new movie that you're in.
But the light,
I just want to change something and let the audience knows,
not regular use.
Jackie Chan.
Uh,
this difference is not comedy action isn't serious.
I want to show the audience and the actor.
Yeah.
You see the movie yet?
No,
no answer.
[inaudible] my note to myself was like,
he's never made me so sad.
It's really upsetting.
Doing an action comedy for more than 50 years and for the last 10 years I tried
to change you.
Let the audience know I'm the actor,
not the actually stop.
So I try very hard to make car.
The Kid,
the kid,
uh,
dragon blade,
you know,
slowly sort of let the audience know,
uh,
he's not the action star.
He's an active,
but they'll help you fight this off.
Yeah.
And also so your costars Pierce Brosnan,
who is also very intense actor and we're also used to seeing him in a very super
swaps by way and I feel like your guys' roles were a little reverse and we
actually had a clip of it.
Okay.
I've been affiliated with the IRS for 30 years.
When I was,
I fought hard against the violence.
I went to prison for what I did and peered my doubt.
No,
I served the politics of both sides,
trying to heal the wounds and bridge the divide again,
my sincere condolences.
There's nothing I can do.
What if your wife and daughter were killed by Paul?
Okay.
Do everything in my power to get justice.
So I for choosing you,
Mr Hennessy,
you would tell me who kill my child again,
I don't know.
You will change your mind.
Thank you for seeing me.
I think we're going to have a great [inaudible].
My friends tell me usually what my movie,
everybody
quiet.
Just
just like that
brings some tissue.
What was your first reaction upon reading the script?
There was seven years ago.
It's no,
yeah,
seven years ago.
I read the script,
I like it very much.
And also the writer is a Jackie only you can do that character because you
should be by the book is called a Chinaman.
Then I loved so much Jen and a writer,
he won't let go.
He wanted to be a director.
And so a lot of studio said,
no,
you're,
you're too new.
We are not rest.
This kind of budget you're looking for a director for.
And later on there's so many politic,
you know.
I said,
okay,
forget it.
Then I go back to China,
they make my own film later on.
Then STX bring,
he wanted to work with me and I said,
why didn't you stop him?
It's foreigner and they,
they saw of all the politics and the teams and everybody,
everybody gets a little bit money and okay,
let's make the film.
Exactly.
So the things that were,
but Martin Campbell ended up tracking it.
It was great when he did go nine with Pierce Brosnan.
The first,
I want to be a,
I want to be a direct myself and if I'm direct,
I'm not that old.
My younger.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
Yolanda,
big action jumping around.
I was a 40 something years old and they don't just sold too many English and the
filming,
uh,
in,
in London,
I think I might not understand a lot of English.
Why don't I find that?
I read too.
So we,
we,
we find that I read,
they introduced Mike Martin Campbell.
Then of course I know him and I said,
yeah,
it's good.
You know when we hired him then we do the casting,
we do the makeup,
then
it takes me when they have our makeup checky are not always
[inaudible] check it.
Yeah.
Not Jackie Chan,
you are gone.
I said okay.
Sometimes you don't want to move [inaudible]
it's interesting because you are playing a slightly older character and centered
versatile choreographer and action star that how do you approach,
you know,
choreographing for our character who is supposed to be
older?
Yes.
We'd have to because my,
my,
my character is like a special force and like a navy suit and know a lot of
skill and those,
those kind of actions you couldn't,
it's not like it used to be checking up fast.
It's more like a killing things
and also you have to watch my age.
Then after use,
uh,
my trick and technique and to,
to,
to win the battery.
Yeah.
Speaking of,
we have one of your battles
[inaudible]
nope.
Huh?
Used to be
I'm over it.
I had to pretend boom.
Okay.
Uh,
I have a pretender.
Pretend.
Oh,
every time I pass the camera,
how do
I have to do these kinds of,
you make the audience believe I'm,
I'm old.
Huh?
You did a great job acting it because like you Finna hurt,
you know,
you seem to be hurting stents in choreography before this.
I was like,
is he okay?
Like you really took a beating in this lot or your character takes a beating in
this one
and,
and very difficult.
Even the very simple action sequence is so difficult to fight.
Why?
Because the director hired the act to really know how to act,
but they don't know how to fight.
That's the problem.
Um,
when did you d
relax
on up on again?
Pop,
pop,
pop.
Okay.
Real action.
I have to on this tech,
teach them how,
how to be a action.
Sometime you will know you,
you,
you know how to fight,
but you do this kind of fun.
You get hurt but it doesn't look good.
Yeah.
You'll have to know the rhythm.
The timing is very important.
So what's your process like when you are starting to choreograph and you've seen
out,
like where do you,
do you start with the script?
Do you
uh,
what kind of like rush hour.
Okay.
Then we know it's a common about happy go lucky and this kind of fighting is a
tough and serious and it's not like Russia fighting.
Yeah,
it's very much,
well
how do you,
how do you kind of continue to innovate because you've been onscreen for such an
amazing amount of time,
but you always seem to bring something new to the table.
Like where do you get your idea?
This round?
I'm just thinking every day he might not drive for,
he had 45 minutes.
I'm on a car.
I didn't think about this of idea really.
When you go the location of vacation,
you go to the
whatever.
And you take a photo with,
I always can I jump from here?
Oh,
come here.
I just where I can shit.
I don't know why he's just,
everything for me is the movies.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
I think that's probably why you continue to,
you know,
push the boundaries of what we watch.
No,
I just,
I don't know why.
So all my mind is a script,
script,
Ashland afternoon,
stunned.
How can you use,
uh,
those kinds of Chia becoming a weapon.
I look it up.
I never saw doing those kinds of extra,
well what can we do?
These kinds of things.
So you just to hold the guy when grab me,
then I pushed back.
Boom.
The 200.
Yeah.
These kinds of things.
I've been looking for everything in my life.
I,
my head is a action sequence.
So when you,
when you have,
you know,
you have all these amazing ideas in your head,
but then you also are working with,
you know,
a team of people and you have to collaborate.
So how did,
how did you and like Martin work together,
how did,
how did that kind of come together on the same page to start or where your style
different showing that in a minute,
which is awesome.
Module.
How long has the fight that went from seven time,
you know,
my movie,
21 half hour.
Keep fighting.
I never die
when they come to us.
I learned
this timing speed.
Uh,
sometime you fight a five minute,
32nd,
10 minutes,
something like that.
Then we decided on a sequence show marquis then too long,
too short and show the camera man showed a prop props.
We just for,
for us,
it's so easy.
You know what we've been filming
all my life actually film actually the sequence.
When you say you show them,
does that mean you actually like block it out and then you'll show it?
Show it?
Yeah.
I have a 17 yeah.
Each team.
Some,
some TV in China.
So I'm keeping Lyndon some team in Hong Kong.
We were choreograph a lot of things you would put together to show Marty.
Yeah,
we have one more fight.
Was there last climb?
Oh,
that's a good,
that's a really one.
Yeah.
What was the most challenging scene to film for this one?
I think every time making an American film mode.
Challenges in English,
you know,
it's so difficult.
No action acting for me.
Easy on the set.
The English is so difficult.
No special in some time do you have it have just be
a cup of tea?
Perfect.
Of course.
I think
yes.
A difficult and also making a American film or the challenge is the timing,
the budget and the schedule.
No,
not making my,
my own feeling when I'm making my own films.
I cannot finish today and puffiness another day we get finish.
Not that they didn't another day.
Make sure the scene are good,
but making American film,
you've got to finish today.
Otherwise the bomb coming,
she'll rinse.
Coming at that drives me crazy,
so that's why sometime I,
okay.
I sometime it just,
I just asked that you want him to go film or you,
you want to make a good film?
I want to make a foot film.
Some stuff.
Some I see some people they just want the on schedule,
on budget,
make the film.
No,
that's wrong.
That's wrong.
Do you think when you work with directors that you kind of bring your work ethic
and style and that they adopt that?
Because I feel like you're such a professional that working with you,
like you kind of have to learn to do that.
That's the problem.
When I'm making a film,
you s you still on the set,
you can,
you do nothing.
Moved.
Uh,
moved the chair.
Stop.
Don't do it.
Props guys.
We have a 20 people on the surrounded.
You just moved to,
no,
you have to wait for the prop guy 20 miles
and bring the,
bring the water away.
There's too many rules,
but sometime you have to follow the rules.
And myself,
we don't have the rules on the set.
I'm the camera man.
I'm the lighting guy.
I'm the prop guy.
I'm the director,
I'm the writer.
I'm stunned.
Connie died,
do anything.
Everything.
Even my stunt team,
we do everything on a sec.
We are included but in us do like a photo American roots.
So this why when I'm making American food sometime on the set,
I ah,
ah,
you know,
this does hold up.
Yeah.
I mean I think for a character like this,
does that actually play into your character here?
Right.
Because you,
you're frustrated as a character,
you're building all this tension,
you know,
your character is in a terrible position and like no one's helping him.
Do you kind of channel into that if you're acting in this
exactly the same.
And I just follow the,
the actor to too.
So you fly in the movie from no tear and do the tear comes up and have to speak
English is not my mother language and I have to remember the dialogue and I
remember the,
the,
the actor,
what he's saying,
what,
when is my turn?
I think my tears coming up going,
I pretend prying.
Then I a pretty good actor.
[inaudible]
the most interesting to me about this one is that I don't think there was a
fight till about like 30 minutes in.
And I think we're so used to seeing you jumped into action.
It was such an interesting and you kind of unexpected thing to see you build to
this fight.
And when it made,
when the first bike does come on,
it's so much more intense because of it.
This kind of movie,
you cannot fight too much.
Otherwise,
the audience belief,
why can you see my character jumped into Skype up above them.
I told us we had to 17 pounds.
Oh No,
you'd have to my,
exactly my,
my,
my character,
I get hit and even a piece,
somebody I kept bit more then I lie down,
but I just use my tricks.
Uh,
my,
my experience too.
When the,
the,
the fighting,
uh,
except Layla parity.
Then you look at the art.
That's the real,
the real movie,
the real things.
Otherwise,
if I can,
uh,
some are sober,
we'll do this summer.
So no,
it's not like these kind of the,
the,
the coronagraph.
Yup.
What do you think you admired most about kwan
humble?
Uh,
[inaudible] she's a little quieter than Mosley.
Empire.
Yeah.
On this set.
On a set.
I'm an on the,
when they're filming,
I'm on the set and I helping everybody and helping your new talent and helping
my stunt stunt team and,
and helping the home.
Oh Ho,
Ho,
Ho the whom movie.
Everything except in front of the audience.
I know you want to do it.
Say Listen,
a lot of things I try to bring up all the things you,
you,
you like to hear and everything I speed is true.
I never make up the things.
Yeah.
All those years.
And that's me exactly like one.
Yeah.
You,
you also produce it.
So it does that,
like when you aren't producing a film,
do you get as involved in every step of it or is that just kind of built into
who you are and you just,
you know,
long story
when,
when I'm making a film sometime I know that editing is wrong.
Uh,
I mean editing myself 40 years and I do everything.
It's,
this is not like a American,
they have a director adding direct to
camera director,
director,
just so many director.
When I'm making a film,
I'm the director and the art director.
I'm editing director and I do everything.
We don't have a money.
People have to do it with my own things.
So this is why you see the Chucky and own film.
Terrible Act.
Our directive.
Terrible camera movement.
We don't want more money to fired Crenn and Dodie.
We use a wheelchair.
We use it.
We use a ladder,
but I learned so many things after I went to come do a u s wow.
I see all the camera equipment.
Then I learned more so this why sometime like,
oh,
okay,
movie like drunken master police story.
Whatever they they,
they bought it.
Come to us.
They have the recap.
We dump sound,
everything.
I said,
why I do the best I can.
Why you have to recut Caribou editing.
Terrible.
You can compare to to my editing and it's okay.
I believe that's American.
Okay.
I trust the,
the,
the editing guy.
I trust the,
the,
the sound guy because that's the way American people like it.
Sometime I asked the American fence,
no,
we don't lie.
American virtue.
We like tried to virgin my own version.
So later on they find out,
oh they need a job.
They cannot
bring it.
They cannot bring a police story come to us.
Oh good.
No depth,
no editing the wrong.
Okay,
you need editing guy.
Musics are wrong,
so you need so many people.
Then you ruined my movie.
So now I want to be a producer,
producer.
Then I said anything wrong.
At least I can say something to tell that directly to duties.
Do that.
Otherwise it's an actor.
You just say it.
Uh,
yeah.
You have no say I wanted to do this.
No know,
don't worry.
Where would,
if I'm the producer,
okay,
I want to change this.
I wanted to do because I'm not the master,
but I'd been in the movie industry of 57 years,
all my life,
every single day in the film set.
Eh,
if I'm not home,
I'm an editing room.
If I'm not in the edit room,
I mean the script meeting,
Eh,
all the time
you sleep
four hour from anchorage.
I just arrive four o'clock from China,
India this morning and I am,
I'm flying back to la.
[inaudible] technology has evolved so much.
And you,
you touched back to it,
like,
look,
you guys use like,
I don't want to say rudimentary,
but use the techniques available to you.
Has Technology impacted you at all?
Really?
In the old day,
I rest of my life because I don't know technology,
I don't know.
Green screen,
blue,
those kinds of computer graphics.
I don't know.
I have to risk my life to all,
all a sudden when I watch American movie,
Wow.
Then everybody can be a soup.
Superman,
Supergirl,
Damon,
they,
even now they do the action secret better than an hour because the user,
especially with her,
uh,
through,
through screen,
green screen,
computer graphic,
uh,
break,
dance,
uh,
martial arts,
all kinds of March or with all the new technologies.
So this is why you see right now American action movies.
So good,
not shorter.
And of course we were,
I want to show the,
the one shot just like this.
You see the whole thing,
what I'm doing,
but I'm not going to feel me.
They clever.
They can use the camera angle if for some,
some people they don't know how to fight.
They just teach
then audit.
Wow.
[inaudible]
I know how to fight.
I don't need these kinds of things yet.
I wanted to 40 or 35 put up the 50 I show you the whole thing.
The whole shot.
Difficult.
Very hard to shut.
Like your master one shot,
two days,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
I'm American things so easy.
One day I can do a 20 shot cut,
boom check pack.
So easy.
But
I think American,
the audience,
they like this car.
The cell you felt with the camera angle is too.
How would you know this guy?
The things,
wow.
Just so good.
But now I know this kind of things,
but the Oregon,
they don't like to see Jackie Chan doing these kinds of things.
They did.
They watch American.
A lot of actions.
Okay.
They,
they can do.
They know.
But if I do these kinds of things,
why
do,
do we have to show the audience the whole thing?
Jump.
Boom.
I get hurt by Uber.
Go to the hospital.
Jackie Chan
pull me.
Yeah,
when I was young,
we don't have money.
We have,
we don't,
we cannot buy a machine who had duties kind of thing.
Today we have a lot of money but still do the stupid cupid,
the weight because the audience,
the light duty digitize things.
And I don't think the audience to see Jackie,
beacon.
Spiderman.
Yeah.
I want to be,
wait,
what?
Oh Wow.
This is so good.
Shoes fighting.
I can use it or they come back
for me.
They want to see no matter how old I am,
you see me doing that action sequence?
Well,
just like you,
you know,
you hadn't done a ton,
but I like to do it.
Yeah.
You have an attitude,
senator.
Super serious ones before and this turned out great.
So you could try and,
you know,
you could try for the next spider man.
Nope.
What the I want.
I want to hire me to be coming.
Uh,
uh,
well back managed by the man.
Every time I see those superheroes,
I should end there.
Nobody hire me.
Your own superhero.
Terrible thing.
Okay.
Rush Hour.
Sean had gone
now the foreigners.
So yeah,
I pick up the script.
Otherwise they still going on and I guess y'all had dawn hour and a cup.
A S C I m Sukup buddies from China.
From Hong Kong.
Oh,
police
in China.
I can do a lot of things because I put him a myself.
So this why you can see I do
all kinds of different character.
But in u s so difficult.
Yeah.
I receive a lot of script,
police,
CIA,
CIA.
I wanted,
I wanted to change.
What do you think you would want to do next if you had like your pick of any
project?
Lanolin [inaudible]
such a good singer.
Like it's not funny
at the end of song
somebody's song.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And if you have a time trends today,
the,
the lyrics.
So good delivery.
So good.
I think that the video is actually already out the music video for it.
Yeah.
And we with our agenda number one,
not,
not the Chris thing.
Probably my voice is sexy.
Lyric is good.
The music is good.
It's so good.
It's good luck.
It's a great song.
Yeah.
We have time for a few audience questions.
If folks on a lineup at the back,
I would love to see you in the La La land.
Yeah,
I would love it.
Like I hope you,
I hope you make it tiny la La land.
Hey Jackie,
I'm a huge fan of yours and uh,
please start it with one of my favorite movies of all time.
What movie please.
Sorry.
Oh,
police start it.
Thank you.
And my favorite part of your movies or when you show the bloopers at the end and
it shows like all the different,
like the outtakes and all the stones that went wrong.
And like in project a,
you fell from the clock tower two or three times.
So I was wondering,
um,
is it hard for you to get the courage to do the stunts over and over again even
after you've been hurt
doing this?
Done?
I actually went to doing stuff.
I'm scared.
I'm not the superman every time when the [inaudible] [inaudible] boom,
boom,
boom.
But I just,
I wanted to do it.
I wanted to challenge myself.
Strange when that,
anytime when this the the camera rolling speed then Ooh,
wow.
I just,
and that time and that moment of becoming superman.
Boom.
I do.
I never thought then I think probably I'm gonna I know I'm going to die.
I'm,
I,
I probably,
I hurt myself.
I don't care at that time.
So this way John Building and how the copter or I just every time did like uh,
seeing death penalty.
Yes.
Nice Super Cup.
You jumped in the helicopter.
Nothing.
There's no way or not.
And you just watched the helicopter.
I'm going to do it.
Yes.
Then I watched across the street so many Paparazzi with Devin.
The Lens,
I got the job.
They would watch you.
I'm dying.
Okay.
[inaudible] next shot.
Yeah,
that's,
but I'm,
I'm,
I,
I'm so happy.
I'm glad when I was young,
I so many energy.
I do so many Stan and I'm so happy this day probably I cannot do anymore.
Yeah.
Jump off the table.
Yes.
But no,
and I might use a special effects suits this.
Why I that technology's so good.
[inaudible] I came from,
he jumped from here to here.
It's like a 20 story building
and the old day,
I really don't
thank you.
Ever since I was a kid,
I always looked up to you.
I always imagine training under you and learning from you.
And because of that I trained Kung Fu ever since I was four.
Um,
now,
uh,
I teach lion dancing two kids.
Uh,
I teach at three different places.
Um,
and I have two other come from others and we collaborate together and we do a
lot of things and we,
we come up with different tricks for lion dance and we'd do all these,
all these tents similar to you but not as amazing as yourself.
Uh,
what I want to get to is um,
working with,
uh,
your Kung Fu brothers Sammo hung and you involve all three of you are amazing.
And I'm wondering what that dynamic was like when you guys were doing your
stunts and your choreography
when some of whom are me and you and bill together.
Just like a minty things.
Yeah.
On the,
on the set when we were off,
we don't give an to train.
We did put the hand that then it just give me a punch.
Then we just,
those kinds of things just come from natural.
Oh good.
You don't have to like a bomb bomb,
bomb bomb.
Some other people we have to.
Okay.
Watch,
watch how punch k.
Okay.
Again,
you forget,
but with young girls,
Emma,
which is very natural,
you put the hemp [inaudible] so good.
Yeah.
Um,
I miss the old day.
Really.
Do you spend a lot of time like actively training and learning new things or do
you spend more time teaching,
teaching,
teaching.
When you're teaching you have so many new things coming up.
And also when I teaching,
I also learned something from the students because they've,
they from some other martial art,
they want to learn the movies.
Then I can actually,
I didn't say that I in my heart.
Wow.
I learned something from him and I use these things and change and other things.
Uh,
actually right now my,
my,
when you look Jackie Chan movie,
it's not just one style.
We have like a wing Joan Jett,
you sue judo.
We have all kinds of it kind of like a jumpsuit,
all kinds of things.
So it's not alleging a ty g just one style have so many style.
So Ashley,
you,
you and you watch your junk and Mazda.
You want,
you're a police story.
There's so many style inside.
Hello Jackie Chan.
My name is Winnie lamb.
And what this audience may not know is that besides you being a famous movie
star,
that you're a passionate advocate for wildlife conservation.
You've done commercials to save tigers,
to save elephants,
to save rhinos and things like that.
What I'm curious is what inspires you to take such passionate action to save
animals and what is your vision for what you would like to see happen
doing a charity Saber animal is the people teaching me how to do it.
I'm,
I never go to school when they were young.
I just do the motto.
Our school when they were growing up when I was 16 or 15 then all my mind is a
daytime crowd.
The afternoon Kido at night boxing,
middle of the night,
and a gym room nonstop.
When I becoming a movie star,
I wanted to make money.
I wonder if famous,
this all laid on,
laid on because the movie's success.
I becoming a famous people.
You just tell me do a chart.
I don't like to toot your charity.
I don't have time to do charity.
I like to play out,
but the ones that I wanted to drink over there with disco,
just I w when I was in 1920 I'm a million year ready every,
every day.
I just,
if you watch my back by other free SBT choose,
I wasn't kind of like,
I'm just
not playboy.
Yeah.
Everyone goes through find the residents.
How one day I involve
one charity and did a young kid.
Uh,
you coming back next year then wow.
It really hurts me.
And also the organizing.
Oh,
Jackie.
He didn't sleep the whole night.
Actually,
I've been playing the whole night.
David asked Jackie Bell working the whole night.
Now I'll come to see you buy so many press and then the all the young kid who
asked me what kind of prison,
I don't know.
It's not been able to,
I didn't buy it.
They buy everything digital organized.
Then I bring up,
I just so shame I go back and never,
never forget the whole,
I see the uh,
the,
the children asked me,
are you coming back next year,
next year,
Christmas.
Then I say yes.
Then that day,
every day just yes,
yes,
yes.
Next year,
Nixon,
oh,
what will you find a stock?
Join him.
God redeemed the field,
right.
Redeemed the queue.
Next Christmas I bring,
I really buys them the,
the,
the press and go back.
Then I said,
ah,
last year was bad.
This year I released comme ci doing any charge.
You like a snowball and you do this.
I said,
somebody that does charity teaching me becoming a good boy.
Good person,
good to respect their need.
Okay.
Animal and it's slowly,
slowly.
I,
you moved so many things now I be cool.
I'm,
I'm good boy.
Now
I was a wild boy when they were young.
You can imagine,
uh,
as done guy everyday risks I would like,
am I gonna
die today?
I do know we do it in the morning,
in,
in the old day you get hurt,
you're done.
So we just risk the life.
Then you get money otherwise to mono,
you get,
you don't have food,
then we just,
that's my life.
So sucked any,
we have a million cash a day.
Wow.
Spend everyday.
And it just,
I don't know when I'm going to die.
And did you know his desk?
Kind of thought.
But now because charity teach me,
become a good person.
Thank you charity.
Thank you.
Own Offense.
Donate a lot of money to me to helping me the charity.
Thank you.
True to,
yeah.
You could go back and give yourself a piece of advice.
Would you or would you,
do you think you had to go on a journey no matter what?
If,
uh,
if you could go back and tell that young Jackie Chan.
Cool.
Yes.
You alone.
A young kid.
I,
but I believe when I was like,
uh,
I have a plan.
I said,
two years I have to study Chinese and piano and ankylosis that's what I'm doing
every day I was training because I didn't never go to school.
You mean Chinese?
I don't know how to read.
So a higher the teacher teach me how to read Chinese,
uh,
two hour after that at night running,
you know,
junk here I see people junky London streets,
the come out with a w with all our girl is drunk.
And then I want you to these kinds of people.
Uh,
how do you say,
just,
uh,
just I said,
yeah,
no useless.
Don't look at these kind of people I have to work hard to fold for,
for next few years.
I want to speak good Chinese.
Good.
Uh,
I wouldn't have speak good English.
I want to know how to play piano.
I don't know what were it hot this something in one year and when just one
movie,
I becoming a millionaire gonna be coming down with a girl.
Okay.
You never,
you never thought it's that important.
This Day.
I'm talking about 20 years ago.
I already know if I can go back,
I really want to do it over again.
Go to school,
pay piano,
speak with English.
Really Chinese.
That's why I'm doing.
But you never returned.
So these two,
Ay I,
I in China,
I'd be,
it was 26 at school are ready to add.
You tell the children,
look,
don't learn from me when you young.
But children,
you don't.
If they,
they don't have experience,
they don't believe you.
No matter how you tell them.
No.
Go to school.
But they'll pay piano.
No.
When they're going up.
Oh,
I regret I should play piano.
But the time we tell,
I tried to tell the children cut out of the shop.
The,
the,
the bad things when I'm doing,
I would tell them that's between these back.
I want you to directly jump into good things.
Yeah.
So this is why I just opened a school and teach children school.
Very important education.
Yeah.
Hi Jackie.
My name is Jackie [inaudible].
I'm from India.
I'm a suit.
You're about euro superstar.
Super hero back in Bacchanalia husband that was there.
I watched your movies when I was young.
Everybody wants money.
Okay?
So at that time there was not much pocket money for me to go watch your movies.
But I had my brother who used to take me the few movies,
which are watch was armor of God.
Paul Story.
Oh,
there was an incident in armor of God where you fell down,
had a big accident.
Um,
uh,
you have overcome that particular phase of life.
How did you work on that particular challenge?
Goes back to the first question as well.
The fear in anybody said,
we'll come and do these stones,
which you do.
How did you overcome that particular field is what is the question?
I don't know.
Let's just do it.
And every time I did,
when I do design this done,
you know,
when you sit down with all my stunt team,
ah,
this,
that,
that's you can we still have a standard stump jump off the tree.
Dot.
Oh,
so exciting.
But when years later by the time is coming,
you just like a wow at death,
depending on with you.
I'm gonna really do this.
I'm so stupid.
There's no such clever way to do it.
The only way just risk your life to do these kinds of things.
Let Hammer of God,
I already read it,
John once.
It's okay,
but I think it's not good enough.
I do it one more time and the tree break.
I should falling down there.
Yugoslavia.
Camera Man,
look at me.
Suppose he put down the camera pushing me.
I'm saying,
Hey,
look at me.
Kicked the camera.
I'd run away.
You see?
Did you see the okay?
Yeah.
You see the outtake
I falling,
falling up.
Granted every trip,
brick,
boom,
magic 40 hours.
Then nothing happened.
I feel my back's gonna hurt.
Did like get up and everybody pushing me back.
I don't know what happened.
And later
southern yet,
and I hear my year blips coming with their ears,
Yugoslavia and that time,
uh,
1212 o'clock,
they may send me to the hospital at night.
Eight hours,
uh,
eight o' clock,
almost a hour.
And it was a waiting.
Not like today.
Everybody can pick a phone call.
We sit,
sit there to call Hong Kong an hour later,
then come call back.
Just so this why in the room.
I just asked myself what I'm doing.
I'm going to die.
Yeah.
Because all my stunt team,
you know,
all my stunt team,
everybody,
it opened the door.
I did
it.
Just see if I hit die dying.
I just,
I do.
I just him by myself,
then myself,
I'm going to die.
Yeah.
It's so easy
what I'm doing for this world,
what I'm doing for this myself.
Nothing.
Every day,
every day,
every day.
Just making a moving,
fooling around.
I don't know if I can survive,
I should do more things.
So this was right after you will start to go back and I start checking him from
Beijing.
So this way stop.
I think.
Uh,
it's a wake up call.
Yeah,
we got the call.
Do you think from a purely like stunt perspective,
if it wasn't a little bit scary for you,
between a little bit too,
a lot scary.
Like as an audience,
we need that.
Like,
we need to have that fear of like,
cause the CG stuff,
there's no stakes sometimes,
right?
It's just like,
yeah.
How,
how like they're going to survive.
But for you as a choreographer,
is it ever or are you like,
yeah,
I know we need to be a little bit scary.
I,
and also I like to challenge myself.
Every movie.
That's the problem.
Every movie I want to do some more dangerous than this one.
When I see it too,
when I look at the audience,
because when you watch this side,
I over what you do.
So all in the audience,
the reaction,
because I hear the sound,
I know what you're seeing because I'd be editing like a six months every
Saturday.
I was just looking at our audience.
If I see the audit,
oh,
it makes me happy.
Yes.
If I can make audient happy,
that makes me a happy,
happy.
Even though,
Bro,
my finger,
I broke it worth.
Yeah.
I just want to make a good action movie.
Good Jackie Chan movie and
you're making art quick.
Like last week.
Jackie,
my name is Ahmed,
uh,
big time fan of yours.
I'm,
I really want to say thanks for you to come here and give me an opportunity to
see you in person.
One of my dream just came true.
Thank you very much.
Um,
my question to you is your recent experience,
um,
being part of Bollywood,
which is Indian version of Hollywood.
If you can talk about that a little bit,
share that experience with me and all of us,
that'd be great.
I know a Bollywood also is a very big,
I've even tried to make a Bollywood movie for a long time.
Yeah.
Seems,
uh,
seems uh,
some argument that myth.
I was uh,
uh,
the,
the actor,
what's his Danielle?
Uh,
the,
the India actress at the end I asked her Monica money.
Kaizen,
can I make two versions?
One version is somehow before we fight with death,
I really want to do that,
but it doesn't work.
I,
last year
we make the call for Yoga.
Yeah.
Then I said,
Carla,
we'll do a body was,
so I,
I tend to in the whole whole thing,
you know,
everybody,
you have a dream.
You had to make my dream come true.
I want to do this.
So why don't we,
yeah.
Well I want to be a police because,
uh,
I,
I think we'll just school.
I can not go to police went up becoming a director.
I ran my old squid or becoming a police.
Yeah.
Because CIA,
I'd be coming,
uh,
I treasure hunter Bollywood and a writer's group body with it.
Then I think I saw,
uh,
the fun.
Yeah.
I,
I'm still looking for some other script with a stun a India acted together.
Thank you.
All right,
and last audience question.
Thank
you very much,
Mr. 10 foot being here today.
And uh,
my name is John Paul.
Lee,
you talked about briefly your frustration with being cast it as,
uh,
being offered a row as police or [inaudible] step several of character.
So I'm wondering what are your thoughts in making the American film industry a
better place for foreign actors to collaborate in different types of roles?
And,
uh,
what do you see yourself doing in making this environment better?
Well,
I think this,
this depends,
the script depends.
The script
had it had to be an Asian character pretty much.
It's not what defines you.
It could have been any,
you know,
when you find a good script,
then
you find a,
so this why in America,
they have a casting director.
We don't.
So when in my movie,
if I know
the villain have to find they're not fun,
I find a villain who really can fight,
but they don't have to add.
They just but find school acting no good.
So later on when you see like police story is so minimal,
I just find a villain who know,
but as the people surround him or Becca,
so I fight with all the bad guy,
the villain at the end.
One time
I think,
find out the postscript,
uh,
we will introduce more American actor to China and Chinese actor to America.
Uh,
and not just like introduced one shaft for the appearance is not like this,
just like dragging blade,
you know,
you find the right script.
Then Adrian Brody and John Cruiser and meet everybody.
The Hey,
the same,
how do you say,
Hey,
fund
the scene.
Ever balance.
There's not just one shot is not like this.
Yeah.
Okay.
My last question is what do you wish you had more time for?
Because it sounds like you're doing so much.
I don't know.
I mean
this year I've been what I'm doing,
well,
I mean I've been doing my own record.
Yeah.
I mean three years now and beef.
Nice night.
I,
I still recording right after recording.
Then I go to the APP at port.
Yeah.
Come here.
Uh,
released this year then at tapping Ninjago a nutjob wish dragon.
PBC,
the one world war day.
One day of the world.
Uh,
to producer for script going on.
So what do you do for fun or is this fun?
Like meeting uh,
the fence and uh,
compensation is fun.
Yes.
Otherwise everyday script script.
Sometime you just sit there.
Just led this a half hour.
You just stopped.
Boom.
You just,
you don't know,
just like Laney is supposed to have a mood.
I suppose I already start the movie already,
but the script doesn't,
it's wrong
to American film.
Five against Buddha and another nother one
dimension the name.
Right.
Because the script is wrong because at the producer so I can stop.
I said no,
I'm not going to because as soon as you start the movie,
the money you just do do,
do,
do too.
It's like water.
If we use stock,
make sure the script is right in the long,
not like the old day.
I don't know.
They just start then movie,
you know,
understand this everyday.
Make the phone call.
Then the,
the the fest coming.
The the the script.
Okay.
Do this scene first.
They haven't read yet.
They start the movie because they want to start the movie.
They just want to make movies.
I want to make a good movie is different.
Yeah.
If I cannot finish today,
tomorrow if I spend another,
no,
I put my own money to make sure the movies are good.
Some Eh,
so this why right now I'm doing,
that's a good thing.
Otherwise I already start to move.
He already then on the set you,
you will,
ah,
why did start the movie?
They have to finish today.
You had to finish in two days.
That's America.
American.
The what?
The,
the,
the rule
schedule sometime makes you angry.
Just they just make movie for schedule,
Budget Day.
Uh,
30 days finished the day,
finished the go within is on budget on day 30 days.
Then,
then everybody celebration that turned around.
I just go back to my hotel.
I know what's going on.
It's not like that.
If I'm 30 day cannot finish six days,
60th can offense two years,
make one movie because the movie live forever.
Yeah.
So these are stills standing here because I want to make a good movie.
That's a so many movie.
Boom.
Gone.
People cannot remember.
So when you do good things,
stay to the past.
Not for today.
For Future.
Sometimes they want,
you want to make a quick money today,
then gone.
You doesn't make any money.
You could put resolved.
Good.
Uh,
something.
I don't know how he said and
when you get,
Oh,
you get everything the wall.
Yeah.
I think that's great advice.
Not just for movies.
I think it's great French,
right?
Yeah.
I tell all my students,
when you make a movie,
I want to,
I want to tell,
uh,
Oscar,
I want to make money.
I want to do this.
You get nothing.
If we,
you stop the thought.
I want to get a horse cart.
[inaudible] I want to make a drama.
I want to get a [inaudible].
No,
you get nothing.
If I just wanted to make a good movie,
that's all you get.
Everything.
Yeah.
I never saw,
I can't get the Oscar
cheap cheap action comedy come full stop.
They would never give me your last car.
Ryan.
You for those kind of Oscar.
I'll only give to what Primo was a Kramer.
Uh,
those kinds of drama scene.
You,
I never thought.
All those years.
I just want to make good movies,
good person.
When I have time to put more charity,
help more people,
there's all,
then certainly I never want on Oscar.
Come to see.
Find me.
It's not,
I'm not going to fly Oscar.
Yeah,
everything.
The money come to me.
I pushed the money the old day.
I want money.
No money.
Then now I just want to have good things and the money come,
Oscar,
come to people,
come fence,
come.
The whole world's come.
Yeah.
So do you have a dream?
Do the good things.
Everything's come.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.